yeah situated in my own lane i'm not in
it for the one time no piercer my train
always on the go
i needed an igloo for my shindu and then
added over there
with that money because i'm not a liar
hey yo what's up it's your boy ksi and
today i'm going to be interviewing
someone who's very special to me myself
hey my g how you doing good how are you
i'm very good geez if i was single oh
you dirty dog nah man you're fit
you're sexy i mean oh my god you're
unreal
damn
well have you been working out as low oh
my god
all
hey right chips of course
and uh walkers oh this could be close
you know
um
let me try the walkers first
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so good
contain chips
okay
well
don't get me wrong
it's decent
not very decent but
this just edges it about yeah
salt and vinegar walkers
literally the best crisps england wins
this round baby
[Music]
all right if you could describe yourself
in three words
which words would you use we were to
describe myself sexy okay
yeah yeah uh
funny oh
you all pretty much
a winner
[Laughter]
you're always winning
oh i'm humble
you know
jokes
you
you're not going to go for knowledge
strength and integrity
i wouldn't say that
oh you
okay um
oh oh my god it doesn't sound anything
alive yeah i'm just so lucky i said duck
how would you do it i'll go
okay yeah yeah even the cameraman's yeah
he's impressed
oh
okay
scrumpy jack
i have no idea where is cider okay
takeem
palm drink
oh
okay
we'll save this
grumpy jack
it's like a recorder leg
right
i'm you
[Music]
[Laughter]
juice what is this
obviously
i'm a man that tastes ah so i know what
ass tastes like this is when you you go
in too deep i have never tried this in
my life and i hope to never try again
the worst
drink i've ever tasted nigeria what are
you doing
england wins fam
oh what is this man
my presence
is mine
what's his name smeagle if i'm not going
wrong no bud the ring person
yeah the precious guy
yes
the ringer
[Laughter]
dobby
who's dobby in london
get good
good girl
[Applause]
okay what is this
so what is
if i'm being honest i have no idea it's
just a spicy
fishy like mix of just
stuff
oh it's nice
now this is a scotch egg
oh
wow
no
no ma'am
that ain't the one finesse that egg poor
chicken
poor chicken man nigeria's the winner
okay uh if you were on death row
what would be your last meal
so i'm just getting lost in your eyes so
sorry uh what was the question again
if you were on death row what would be
your last meal i don't know just
probably just chicken yeah so nando's
maybe yeah yeah i mean yeah we all love
nando's uh what's your what's your
favorite spice uh
hot really no i'm kidding yeah
every medium would be medium i'm not
that black
[Laughter]
well and uh
today i
think
it's a good day uh my party just
got voted in joe biden oh so close i'm
the same color as ksi oh obama
sometimes you got improvised
there we go
oh
it's empty it's
so african man
there we
go one
oh
oh mate i don't even need to try these
oh my god oh it's been so long ah ah
get low there
yeah i'm taking these from
yeah yeah yeah yeah man tastes like
heaven baby
true
love there's always like cringe in it
let me sight yeah i'm on the point goes
to nigeria
yo it's your boy
yo it's your boy
[Laughter]
youtube are boxers uh i i like to make
music now
don't know glover
all right what has been your career
highlight so far probably just
looking at you man
yeah like this is a huge moment for me
we i just
meant to be together we are we are just
so amazing the things we've done
the people we've beaten in the ring oh
my god the accolades we've achieved in
music the accolades we've achieved in
youtube we're just we're on fire we're
untouchable right now yeah this is the
most favorite interview that i've ever
done bro this is the best interview i've
ever done legit after this interview we
got we got a tour
and i'm talking sexually
because i'm turned on
jesus
you can't be so stupid sometimes love
you though i love you too
[Laughter]
i started
falling into this
pattern of just doing trends seeing what
was you know hot and just jumping on it
yeah i just wasn't happy so
i was like i'm going to make myself
happy
and i'm going to do
stuff that you know i didn't think i'd
ever want to do